de contamination donc encore très
important en france et ce malgré
l'instauration du pass vaccinale en
début de semaine on en parle justement
avec notre éditorialiste c'est l'édito
politique de nicolas vidal
bonjour nicolas vidal bonjour olivier
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france alors c'est la première
semaine d'application du pass vaccinale
en france comment ça se passe eh bien ça
se passe comme ça doit se passer lorsque
vous avez une telle équipe de champions
du monde qui entasse les contre-vérités
sur des couches de mépris d'inepties
d'arrogance en s'accrochant comme des
morts de faim à une belle stratégie de
l'échec et tout cela a commencé avec
jean doliprane qu'ils savaient
apparemment tout le monde que le conseil
constitutionnel avait validé le pass
vaccinale alors comment ça s'est passé
olivier et d'un jean castex en
conférence de presse le 20 janvier
dernier nous annonce est frais comme un
gardon de prades que le pad vaccinale
entrée en vigueur lundi et comme tout
bon manager bon star thème des chaînes
qui se respecte il avait dû brainstormer
sur le pape avec lolo du conseil
constitutionnel qui lui même avait fait
un feedback en cov cols avant la
deadline donc kamba laisser peser jean
doliprane appris le lit d'un imposant
asap le pass vaccinale à des millions de
français donc depuis lundi ces mêmes
millions de français sont interdits
d'avions de trains de bus interrégionaux
de café de mon talent aux deux formules
midi de plats du jour de théâtre de
stade et de médiathèque mais consolons
nous à cette heure car les manifs sont
encore permise mais il ne faut jamais
désespérer chers amis mais je vous
préviens je vous préviens armez vous de
votre patience la plus solide car la
bande de virologues gouvernement n'a pas
fixé de limites ni des indicateurs
sanitaires pour nous enlever la laisse
n'oubliez jamais que le passager car
devait être supprimée fin novembre et
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons avec le
super passe vaccinale qui ne sert à rien
et qui aurait dû lui aussi être levée le
7 février et maintenant olivier la
science nous dit finalement non ça sera
trop tôt mais bon on n'est jamais que
12e texte de loi pour cette crise
sanitaire en même temps le premier tour
présidentiel c'est le 10 avril donc il
faut savoir faire durer le suspense mais
sans emmanuel macron qui a décidé de ne
pas participer aux débats du premier
tour magistrat de la part du petit
mozart de la démocratie au liban nicolas
gouvernement assure pourtant que le pass
vaccinale c'est la meilleure arme contre
l'épidémie alors oui y'a un truc dont je
suis sur l'île personnellement c'est que
lorsqu'ils ne seront plus là mais qu'est
ce qu'on va s'embêter 15 qui vont nous
manquer comment me passer de bruno le
maire le ministre en chef de la bourde
cela voudrait dire que je ne pourrai
plus entendre bruno le rigolo chez nos
confrères de france info comme ce fut le
cas lundi dernier qui a dit écoutez bien
ça ça vaut son pesant de cacahuètes et
je cite le pass vaccinale sera d'autant
plus efficace qu'il protège des
restaurateurs et les hôteliers
décontamination et ça leur permet de
rester ouverts fin de citation comment
se passer de ce trait d'esprit cette
vivacité intellectuelle car je vous le
dit depuis les sommets nous sommes face
à des intelligence supérieure même si
n'importe quel gamin de primaire voit
bien que ça ressemble à une sorte de
gros flanc sanitaires leur histoire un
plusieurs mois de passer ni terre des
centaines de milles contamination par
jour mais bon plus c'est gros plus ça
passe enfin de moins en moins parlons
aussi de l'île et veyran et variant en
parlant aux gouvernants je sais plus il
commence à sentir le vent du boulet
vaccinale celui-là même s'étonner en
début de semaine que neuf millions de
français vaccinés allait devenir de
quelques jours des plus tout à fait
vacciner alors là olivier d imprégner
les coquins quick nada wesh que chez
wall ou plus d'avions pu être un pull
lucent et régionaux put café plus de
monde talent au plus deux formules midi
et vous connaissez la suite oui parce
qu'en réalité ça commence à ruer dans
les brancards enfin ceux qui restent
parmi les samis 700 lits supprimés
depuis le début du coc vite dans nos
hôpitaux car le trio d enfer mist
n'avait manifestement pas prévu que des
nuances français allait se rendre compte
de la grosse tente talonnade olivier
alors est ce que ça veut dire un nicolas
que le gouvernement pourrait être
contraint de moduler sa politique
sanitaire mais en réalité je vais vous
dire il le faudrait un quart se passe
d'accident est une insulte à
l'intelligence et à la médecine mais
j'ai peu d'espoir car maintenant qu'ils
ont tenté d'emmerdés 6 millions et
quelque de nos vacciner sans succès ils
vont devoir faire face à une armée de
non vaccinés et de pas tout à fait
vacciner qui ne vont plus se laisser
conter fleurette dans le centre de
vaccination d'une zone commerciale n 2
derrière en fast food qui aura lui même
fermé à cause du pad vaccinale ça sans
compter la grosse bon ben balancé par
jean françois delfraissy cette semaine
qui nous a parlé du vaccin médicaments
dans l'indifférence la plus totale alors
même cette déclaration remet
profondément en cause la politique de
ciel du gouvernement et que pfizer bosse
déjà sur le vaccin anti au micron donc
si je comprends bien on a ministre
depuis des mois un médicament des
millions de gens pas malade france très
franchement départ en dur alors même
embourbé on voit bien que le
gouvernement n'est pas prêt de lâcher le
feuilletage de la crise sanitaire et
vous savez c'est la vieille technique du
fumigène qui permet de ne pas parler du
bilan catastrophique des manuels macron
à deux mois et demi la présidentielle et
finissant ce matin charles iv par cette
citation de marcel proust et je cite la
nature ne semble guère capable de donner
que des maladies assez courte mais la
médecine c'est un excellent art de les
prolonger et liés merci nicolas l'édito
politique de nicolas villa l'a retrouvée
bien évidemment sur les réseaux sociaux